what's the um what's the news saying in
Romania about Tate at the stage uh Drago
says there any update are they uh I'm
sorry yeah there's a lot of stuff that's
going on
um
the um
powers that be
yeah so we call them this
are using intermedia against him
and it's so awkward to see it like they
take parts of old materials and they
reuse them to like their new news right
their recent news but once you open the
the
article and read it maybe from halfway
down you realize that it's not something
new it's just repackaged old information
just so that it's negative and against
him right well there's a lot of there's
a lot of content out there where he said
some very outlandish things that are
that are always going to be twisted
against them right I mean that's why you
got to be careful about your public
presence and what you state because it
doesn't forget yeah how much of that was
an exaggeration of him going into more
of an online character than him most of
it I would say he's he's definitely a
caricature of himself right I mean like
I'm like you've met him in person right
Drago's like is he like himself on the
internet
um
he's actually a very pleasant and
um inspirational person yeah and
not at all Brash and
um the word that's coming up to mind is
friction right it seems that when you
hear him talk on
YouTube you get the feeling that
whenever you're gonna meet this person
you won't get along because there's
going to be some type of friction and
that just that just doesn't exist in
real life with him
um yeah I I had a couple of whiskeys
with them at the Trump Hotel in DC I
think in 2017. I didn't know who he was
I just heard the English accent and
maybe in Irish I said oh you're English
we started chatting and then somebody
was like so what are you and Tay talking
about I said who is he I didn't know who
he was genuinely you know I hold my hand
up I had no idea and I would just
chatted had a few whiskeys and he was
nothing like what you see online he was
just it was just funny and unaffable
yeah likable yeah like about likable guy
you know just shooting the shooting the
crap like we're doing but I mean people
take everything out of context right I
mean if you say anything that's that's
you know that can be manipulated or
taken out of context and benefit the you
know the media narratives and you know
they don't do it it's you know it's a
valuable lesson I think you have to pay
attention to right I mean it's it's it's
it's one of the reasons why I think I've
always made you know maintain
consistency in my message when I'm in
front of the camera versus like a lot of
you guys have met me in person like uh
well sorry not German drugless yet but
you know aside from our private zooms
you know about the business Forum but
I'm always consistent like I am you know
like you're going to get what you see
sort of thing right yeah well that's why
I wonder about the tape thing because
when I tell stories especially on my
channel I I can get excited and get
really animated it's still the same
story but I can get not necessarily
embellished but I can get a little
colorful and uh present myself like a
caricature so that's why I ask about the
tape thing I I I've sensed that in him
too that it is core he seems like a
chill guy but you get that energy going
and it's not hard to and plus you get a
laugh and you get attention and guys
that know we talk about it in the dating
thing all the time when you learn how to
tell good stories you read the audience
in real time as you're doing it and it
does work it gets a reaction but in his
case it got a negative reaction
apparently yeah you know we all know him
for a long time but we all know what he
was targeted because you know what
what's Romania from from here it's what
five thousand miles is it
and it's because of his worldwide reach
to young men as I said my son came off
the school bus one day and asked me did
I know Andrew there I said yeah I had I
heard of Andrew Ted not that I know him
personally and I said why he said
because all him and his his buddies
watch his videos on the way home in the
box and this is the powers of me the
Matrix did not want young impressionable
men learning while he was preaching
that's it show me the crime show me the
man and I'll show you the crime
and now it seems that he might have some
medical issues I don't want to exactly
say what the the rumors are
um you know they've already said that
he's got um yeah they're claiming tumors
in his uh throat uh lungs
and apparently they've done a biopsy and
they're benign you know according to
assessed Sterling Cooper posted
something in the last day or so and they
said that the um
biopsy was done in Romania under the
Dubai surgeons request and apparently
it's benign so
um
probably nothing there but we'll see I
don't know
yeah
um and they're using the
Communications that he had with his team
or whoever's talking to him while he's
being detained
as a reason to not uh set him free
because they said okay you telling
whoever you're talking to that you want
to go to Dubai for treatment
is actually
um you saying that you want to escape
home
detention
what are they going to charge them with
at the end of the day like what are they
going to try to stick them with
well I can tell you what information is
public and they have four or five or six
um accusations each charges right and
yeah but is this a girl thing or is it
the money laundering thing like what is
it exactly there's no money order okay
so what are they going to try to pit him
with then there's
um human trafficking there's
um
and we're the consequences for that in
Romania as far as jail time
it kind of depends uh it depends if it's
done with violence or not I don't know
the the actual let me let me look for
the information so when the girl
voluntarily comes over and posted on her
Instagram and then her boyfriend finds
out and gets mad and calls the FBI is
that like what does that fall into
um strong men strong men don't use
violence weak men use violence so I'm
gonna put all my chips on him not using
violence because it went the only
violence he would have to use is to keep
women away from him so you know yeah
guys that get girls you're right it's
kind of the opposite yeah and you're
like you get annoyed you're just like
Jesus Christ can you leave me alone yeah
and it did three to ten years
yeah you know it's it's it's put how you
know this is political because every
political hit job is generally a sex
type of thing it's and there's only one
person ever to just absolutely destroy
that narrative and that was the bad
orange man
and you can throw what you want at him
and I think that's the reason why they
don't want it out around bail is because
they know that he'll have an army of
people behind him and I I think they're
creating a bigger batter well not a
bigger batter but they're going to
create it they're going to end up turbo
charging him
well
yeah it's just that they came on so hard
against him and it it seemed very rushed
when it happened right and well I'm
about I'm 35 years old and I've seen a
few public
um media executions right
uh in the political scene in Romania and
this is exactly that like they want to
make him out to be
um the
Apostle of Apocalypse they're making him
out to be like this incredibly
dangerous malefic
uh bad for society man like
um
is
pushing out there like in that yeah yeah
yeah and like people are looking at this
and that it's just too much right and
they're like people normal people
are looking at the news and they're like
for normal people Andrew Tate is a as um
pimp right that's the the label
that they put on to him right they don't
care about the com the cars the money
the whatever the lifestyle right
to them he's just somebody that made
money from
um sex work or content I don't know
whatever you want to call it even though
that's not true that's not how he made
most of the money it doesn't matter
that's what people label him as and
people look at the news and they're like
okay
so he's a pimp that got
um
arrested not yeah detained not arrested
why is he still on the news why are you
trying to attack this person which is
now being detained right another person
I think it's the ideas at this stage
exactly yeah but what I'm trying to say
is that it's obvious for mainstream
people to look at the news and say okay
this is wrong
he got detained but you don't need to
Massacre His Image like why are you
still talking about this that's what
normal people see and feel at this point
because I'm talking to my friends and
some of them know about him and some of
them know about his content and his work
right but there's a lot of people that
don't because he speaks in English and
like some Romanian people don't
know English that well so there's a
language barrier right and a lot of the
people that are somehow separated from
this uh whole manosphere and internet
and YouTube life just look at this and
say okay like something's wrong here
somebody's trying to attack him because
we've seen it happen before and it's so
obvious that it's like
um not working anymore
they're giving too much attention is
that the yeah if you saw how that's the
wrong type of attention
you need to see like again I'm trying to
make you understand that normal people
see him as a pimp and that's about it
they don't care about the cars like why
do we need to see the the pimp on in the
news every single day in the newspapers
yeah everywhere they waited if you see
how they took out Milo ianopoulos if you
remember Milo Milo star was Rising he
was on with Bill Maher he was at the top
of his Arc and that's when they struck
this rock and rooted after he was Alma
Piers Morgan after he literally you know
it blew up all over the Internet he was
becoming mainstream becoming legitimate
and that's when they had to come out
they knew this stuff for a long time but
they waited at the right time to strike
and yeah
certain people get there they did it
when they wanted to I think they did it
when yeah Romania because he was in
Dubai
after the thing that happened in April
and he only came back for
um
he was one of the most expecting another
kid and he came back they came back to
Romania for the uh holidays and that's
when they detained them but it was
I think they would have wanted to do
this
um
sooner right after April and now it came
to light that those two chicks that
um called the cops on them
they were talking about making a movie
and selling it to Netflix about what
happened in this uh situation
and extorting the guys and there was
like there's a lot of stuff that it's
not in a mainstream media but happened
and it's like I don't know why the
prosecutors and the judge is not taking
it this into account even one of the
supposed victims that was
um
being labeled as a victim
she came out and said but I'm not a
victim I did this willingly and I don't
want to be constituted as a victim in
this case
and they brought up psychologists to
label her as brainwashed and oh yeah
yeah I saw that too yeah if you watch if
you watch the video if you watch the
viewer the Ellen show for two days in a
row you're technically brainwashed in my
books and
um if you listen to
um when Joe Rogan had Russell Brand on
the other day if you listen to that
podcast everything that's going on here
will be completely clear to you as to
you know it's not a conspiracy theory
like the the best part about that uh
show that I listen to the most stunning
part was when Joe Rogan said Alex Jones
came up to him about 10 years ago and
that Alex Jones was like ranting and
raving about this sex Island that this
billionaire had that they'd fly
politicians and business people out
there and they'd have sex with young
women and compromise them and Joe Rogan
says yeah I rolled my eyes at him and I
was like yeah Alex Jones conspiracy that
sounds crazy
now we're at the stage where Epstein
didn't himself you know yeah so there is
a there is a matrix there and it picks
out targets who try to break out of the
Matrix
I think it allows people to go through
too like the Milo that you guys
mentioned and then and Andrew Tate so my
question is who's the next Rising Star
because there's a cycle there will be a
point where people stop caring about
Tate and then he'll just kind of
disappear into the ether it'll be two or
three years later and like oh yeah what
happened to that guy and you'll Google
him and he's like living you know some
normal life somewhere because that's
it'll be the next guy that's just like
rabid and louder
yeah they'll pick their next Champion to
allow to rise to that level of stardom
and then they'll then then they'll break
them down too yeah so do the same thing
with pop stars
oh yeah I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out